but more a little more open okay so it's
not going to be a crash or anything uh
but still keep it slow because you're
really you're really trying to train the
mind what is my mind
um so uh you're you're okay you can do
whatever strikes take
down okay and then you can do whatever
uh but we don't have weapons okay uh but
keep it slow
um don't kill each other
okay the mind will reveal itself okay
all right so uh here we go he's going in
[Music]
foreign
find it
one more apply that go
ES
[Music]
all right
here we go
so your Keyhole advisor gives you if you
don't understand it
it gives you the illusion of agency but
Jiu Jitsu is not about agency so you're
like I can't tilt him
you have to he has to tilt himself
okay so
we're going right so here it is right
there go go do whatever so that pressure
when he push my hand down do you see
so he's here he clears my hand pushes
down and there's the toe
you see that's the joke
then you have yourself
but your tilt is from the yield
so if you look you're gonna do koku hole
right
and a lot of people do like an arm
manipulation
but he's pushy and that energy is what I
use
to get this one
when you're not working
the tilt is much smaller your
tilt is much smaller so say where you
are don't move don't move
okay
it looks like
he's upright but if you look at his
shoulders he's not
you see that
you guys see that so it's not now kilo
but it is
conceptually what you're doing and so
and now I don't go for it because I can
feel his power he's trying to not go if
he's trying to straighten it it's when
he straightens it that you have okay
so I'll try to demonstrate that watch
How It's micro
tilt not
the big key on the line okay
they're even on that one when it came
around
you see tilted
so watch what
when he goes for it no way
you see
go for it and there's the Tilt just
split closely
lower shoulder higher shock you see if
he's passive I'll get it
but now he has to react to it so he does
react to it and then that's where you
get your thing
he reacts to it
but
[Music]
go keep going
don't
it's very it's everything is exaggerated
for training purposes so
understanding it conceptually means not
exactly
like he who
let's go
so since you're training obviously
you're not fighting because you don't
have your weapons right
so you're training and so you make this
kind of specialized environment
where you could observe
these skill sets okay you have to first
know what are these skill sets and never
confuse these skill sets with
the totality okay
so
um when you do your idea
I talked about how there's points
in the form
where you're going to basically do a
standing meditation right
um all you should look for those points
here too
okay
so a few pages it's deceiving because
you can't feel it they only you can feel
it you see
um so I'm trying to talk my way so this
this situation here is already some
specialized skill set because if I had
weapons I wouldn't be here see that I
think the only way to be here with
weapons
is
he he got me in the corner of these
things
you get he's closer than that you'd have
to be close we're here like that and now
now we're into
that rank so we don't need the corner to
practice that range
got it okay and so since I hear I want
to practice that range
not practice fighting
when he goes eventually
keep going dude I'll talk I'll tell you
to stop with you so when he goes you see
his little see his little hook punch
that he got as I'm coming in
that's not going to do what he thinks
he's what what he thinks he's gonna do
because I'm moving past it into here
do you think but look at the Tilt that I
got
you see
so you can hit me harder with that boom
it's not going to do what he thinks it's
going to do okay but I got the tilt okay
and now it looks
uh let's push into each other it looks
no don't let me push you hold your base
it looks like we're doing that
but
I'm just here right
you feel push into me do you feel that
difference now I'm here push
this is different so it's not so in
other words push into each other and
quickly get out of the way then you'll
see me falling
I am pressing or I am touching him but
as he's pushed into me I'm just grounded
if he quickly moves out of the way
it's like he was never on me you see
that but I get I want to practice that
range
but when I practice when I get here you
have to not want the question to him
it's your place like in the item where
you're just
relax and relaxing and he's pushing on
you you see and part of that is if you
pay attention I don't try for this move
here I don't try for that tilt I go
ahead and let him respond to the tilt
you see
and I oh no well I didn't get what I
want so he's going to eventually push
because he went back out and that's
where I can stand here and again if I
know I'm touching him but I'm not
driving into him driving to me I'm not
driving into him I'm just here so if you
push this we don't go anywhere you can't
push you see if you let go really fast
it's like I'm not doing anything
so here again I'm here and here's where
the ego tripartite mind wants to get
something
don't
train he does something go ahead I don't
hey she does something
[Music]
do you understand and so if you look at
it even though
it looks like fighting is not fighting
and training my mind and so I try to
trigger it with grounding I release the
trigger that happens and I release the
desire to do something and the desire to
stop something
you see
so just like in the idea in those
moments
release
the fear release the desire uh to do
something release the fear of having
something happen okay and who cares like
he got me a normal Plata that one time
like that was badass I don't need to go
like
okay
so we're going again and I'll try you
guys you just keep going so again it
looks like I'm driving like that
but he's moving back and I'm staying
with him
I'll get myself in that situation again
watch your balls
can't handle Lefty
balls
okay he's moving eye sticking with him
foreign
[Music]
I'm just maintaining contact
can you go forward now
[Music]
working okay
okay
all right let's go
okay and so I was waiting for you if you
weren't going to say it I was going to
say
okay you're just lost
right
and so you you finally expressed it
correctly like I don't know what to do
[Music]
and as I said the only reason you're
asking that question is how do I move
past
not knowing what to do how do I solve
for this problem you see
and generally there's
there's only two reasons why it mattered
that this manifest I don't know what to
do I'm lost you see so someone is coming
in with all these attacks and I was like
oh oh do you see
so these are actually
the two rings
on the dojo press you have three Wings
on the dojo press there's a two on the
side the two solutions I'm going to give
you okay
um
it's it's the it's shuhadi is what that
little pyramid makes but it's the it's
the tripartite or the Triune cosmology
and you're saying you have two things
but really there's just one where you
work in these Trias I think
but shuhadi you have form and non-form
or form and the deconstruction form
and then you have this other state
that's somewhere
perfectly balanced in the middle
which would be the reconciliation of
form and non-formal
that's the crest in the turkey
um
they're in the diamond shape because
traditionally the diamond is
representative of the Mind
especially
the freed ego tripartite Mark the god
mind the Buddha mind
but if I didn't bring this a little bit
down to earth
I just wanted to point it out
you're in the place where you do that
and
where you stop being lost
but the two solutions are well you have
to have some form
and your form has to be able
to address
all the things that are coming up here
okay so for example not many
nagawaza did you see that
okay and so I've already commented on
this many times
and Ronin you can chime in as the UK why
was there not
many nagewaza if any
anyone can talk
because
there was no one Bridging the Gap with
the energy that would facilitate okay
well let's do a little better and use my
phrases
you're all you're right but I would like
my destiny to understand it in my
phrases since your job is to
gain transmission here
where do I call that
I know it's Young spinal displacement
final displacement so his his office had
no spinal displacement to it do you see
now you can answer this Jordan because
you would know but the rest you should
be able to see this why was there no
spinal displacement
[Music]
what no
who did so think about it you see that's
that agency that a lot of people that do
Aikido they don't understand but even
even modern competition Arts like the
modern Jiu Jitsu they don't understand
they see there says they have a lot of
agency to their Jiu Jitsu making it not
Jiu-Jitsu anymore
so and hence why they can't fight bigger
people anymore do you see uh they have
to have weight categories it's like it's
a decade a few decades ago that's what
you were supposed to do but now they
just go no strength matters you see
weight matters is like
sold itself for I don't know probably a
thousand years with no weight and
strength does not matter
because they're like where are the
evolved culture we know oh they didn't
know what they were doing what about if
you just suck at it and you can't do
what they could do about it maybe that's
a plausible answer as well not according
to our theory of evolution yeah
that okay so
it's not that I stopped him from doing
it I would want him to do it you see
so see if you could put it together with
that clue why did he not why was there
no spinal displacement why
[Music]
what did what was he allowed to do in
the drill
anything
do you see so any counter any kind of
attack do you see that oh he feels
himself going off balance what do you
think he did
regained his balance either he regained
it going forward no because he would go
into this you see that so he's making
these little micro adjustments to try to
stop any kind of that young energy that
would lead to a spinal displacement lead
to becoming a spinal displacement tactic
he may have done it like once two two
three times I think in there but even in
the midst of the throw he was reducing
how much spinal displacement he did and
so you don't see the big kihon do you
see that
but in real fighting right boom I I
slammed and there was like a juji Naga
or something in there and he went down
on all fours right now and I do not draw
my weapon you see this thing's over okay
and here it looks like it was nothing in
real life that that whatever you watch
the video where did the opening come
whoa Thunder Down on all fours with the
GG nugget DC you get it
now don't look for the big no you wasn't
especially in a drill where
as a trained aikidoka is gonna go I'm
not smiling to play displacing that
do you see that like you
know he's constantly countered he was
constantly countered it might look to
you like it's one two but no it's like
100 plus 79 10 11 12 got it do you
understand there's constant little micro
countering going on
and that's the funness of the drill it's
like can you adopt with this
ever-changing situation
so
you would need to have form or waza that
would be able to address all of these
things see if all you're doing is q1 was
that
it's not going to work here because he's
never going to give you the Tactical
opening for nagawasa do you understand
and this is where most Aikido people go
I would jcd me
you say well now you're doing spinal
displacement on another trade aikidoka
so see where that lands you
get it
um
so may you look at you okay
we have to come back to the training
equation you see you if you if you don't
believe me you could look at who was
more successful on the mat
calculate their weekly schedule against
the less successful on the map their
weekly schedule and now times that by
what is it how many 72 weeks
is in a year 52 weeks in a year and now
you're that's like we shouldn't have to
look any further do you understand that
do you guys get that but a lot of people
don't go that a lot of people go no no I
know all the techniques that they know
you know what I mean and you probably in
terms of academically
do you see but in terms of getting that
to where it functions more through a
metacognition as opposed to straight
intellect that training equation is
everything
okay do you get that okay so you got to
go there do you do you have
for example I think we could take the
the three Senpai in here and they're
doing a mixture of very similar to what
you saw me doing it's like
striking throwing grappling ground
fighting back to striking back to
locking do you see that
okay so now
well
you might know all your kihon was uh but
do you know all those locks you know all
those counters all the takedowns you
know so like I I think in the first
break uh Ronan did Homo Plaza do you
know om La Plata do you know what I mean
and at what level
do you understand that
um do you know it enough to see it from
upside down
to three rotations in the spiral like he
saw it you see or even as I was go oh
you got it it was like two three moves
away do you see do you see it there
probably not so form is part of the
problem and form is a problem of
training equation you just don't have
enough hours there's no way around that
or you don't have enough curriculum
there's no way around it
no amount of God mind is going to
manifest
form do you understand that do you get
that garma is not about manifestation
ego tribe pie chart mine is about
manifestation
thing
and then the other reason why I might
feel lost and I'm not doing can't do
anything and I don't know what to do is
I cannot access my forms
I cannot access them at the speed of
light spontaneously and this is where
the god mind comes in
so if and I was watching you you would
eventually you would eventually see what
was coming in
but you were like I would say a second
and a half after
you see that so you're it you stayed
completely in a reactionary mode
not in the here and now and so that and
that's what the ego tripartite does that
it's either you're either early or late
you can't be in the present
that's what the god mind can be in the
present okay and so you're chasing
things right that they're already gone
or you're falling for fakes because you
were predicting them you see now it's
like man I can't get anything going and
that's that sense of that okay so when
it comes to access it this comes to the
skill uh can I release from the ego
tripartite mind can I reconcile Fear Can
I reconcile desire can I free myself
from those things like as in one of the
blocks that I that I should see
and that's a skill
it's not a a
State it's a skill that you develop
again and as a skill then is it to not
related to the training equations
you see so again it's not that
we just saw in the three senpai
a bunch of forms but we saw the fluidity
and the adaptability you see that's that
other part and again if you go and you
you calculate that like you you want to
be a coach do you see you let's say you
want to be a coach you know I see okay
that athlete is getting this to work
right not that we're athletes but
they're getting after work what do they
do you see and you would plot for it you
got a plot for the hours you see and I
would say as I've always said man get to
the do the hours first and then start
plotting for uh you know lesson plans
and training environments and all that
kind of stuff because people with hours
can overcome bad Futures bad schedules
uh bad information
people don't realize that
because they're they're sold on this
academic intellect kind of thing but
I've seen people uh I remember when I
was racing and I was at this was early
on I was at National level uh there was
a kid from Alaska
uh hey is that a Mecca of anything do
you know what I mean but he just worked
harder
he worked harder
or he worked hard enough to overcome his
poor environment his poor training
environment you see I was trained as a
as a teenager with world champions
you're going to get fast you see that
but you don't need the world champions
to get past you just gotta work harder
because you don't have World
Championships
and that kid was every bit as
competitive as everyone you and he was
tougher because it's going to make you
tougher see you do all that kind of work
and stuff
so and that's just been my experience if
you wait for the ideal teacher and the
ideal lesson plans and the ideal
schedule you're really missing out
you got to do whatever it takes
right to what you want to accomplish and
what you want to accomplish here is that
middle diamond
do you understand not you know I don't
want all the forms that's not enough
right and they want to be able to do
something okay
but I'm after the middle one and I will
do whatever it takes and what I'm
telling you to start is you have to
start with the training equations
okay I'm not saying it's the end-all but
it is the place to start and there's no
point going Beyond it
if you haven't yet achieved it
if you have achieved it then we can
start looking at other things okay and
so that your question was how do I stop
being lost and I would say get the
training equation first
and then we'll go from there
okay that's that's how I answer that
question okay
[Music]
okay so remember the art is concentric
so you shouldn't you can't you can't
posit
or sparring or whatever in contrast to
your form strain
the pattern means that you you have to
you are supposed to reconcile form and
non-form which means that dichotomy is
not true
do you understand okay so right now form
G was or looks totally different from G
was it but it's not at a conceptual
level
is no matter their best intentions they
never can come in a hundred percent
exactly the same way they count okay yet
you must end up the same way so in my in
my opinion
true key one was that is harder than G1
because the ending has been set for me
it's no matter what he does
I have to make sure he ends up in the
same place
by the same Concepts in geoaza I get to
pick what how he wants to end you see
that's G was of me is actually way
easier than Keyhole lessons
but most people do kiwan Maza and the
way they might do G was that where
they're younging everything and forcing
everything you see
so well I don't know let's say let's say
we'll we'll just we're doing see what he
wasn't here we go that has nothing to do
with what I just saw okay but it's a
level of mind and it's exactly the same
so uh as as he goes right
I can tell you he's pushing down
did you feel it okay
so we'll try to duplicate it again but
normally what's he supposed to do he's
supposed to push in but he decides he's
changing and he started to push down you
see that so when he pushes down if I now
try to go up like the normal form then
I'm young
do you understand so you push down and
I'll go here
and so I'll do it again for the camera
see so normal form don't push down
normal form is here there was no
downward pressure on it so he supposed
to push down for me to push up now that
would be yum yum that's no different
than uh he's coming in on me and me
doing that
you see me pushing on him externally
mechanic
so instead we'll go here I don't know if
you can see it Taylor you probably have
some problems
okay so he had that power pressure so
I'm gonna go down and go behind him
you see that so all uh you can push
straight or you can push down okay you
got it and we'll just we'll do the
position we'll start over and you'll go
again
no he's gonna go
so it looked like you do not pay
attention it looks like the same
technique but you're supposed to go uh
Dave went down on one and it went up on
the other and now you gotta reverse
engineer oh he's not just doing Style
he blessed to push down but usually you
can't you don't make that conclusion do
you think you got it so as as we're
moving on with the form
okay and look you you can see because he
came back
if you paid attention
so he went back and then he came back
forward well that's gonna be young right
here do you see that hey so he goes he
goes back and forward that now I just
clap
you see that as I tried to enter against
that so you would you would feel that
he's coming back
[Music]
you understand you guys would never
notice that because it looked the same
to you but there's actually a G1
somewhere you're harmonizing in and yawn
at all these little micro levels that
you do in the drill like that
you see that so if you just have a form
and you're like all right
and yeah you try to do that every time
that is abiding in the form the form is
dominating
you're supposed to feel what the Duke is
doing and not violate the concepts of
the art so if you feel gone you don't
press into y'all you release at the
moment of yawn do you understand that
okay so that doesn't look like my Aikido
you can see that like I would be
exhausted if I had to train like that
and I'd probably be really strong like a
bunch of the aikidoka out there and get
strong because they're just
pushing people all day long do you
understand okay
um
so we'll do that technique and you're
going to without it looking like you
stopped make these micro adjustments and
you're going to see
yeah I'm not I can't do that either okay
you know what to do
but you can't access what to do okay all
right let's see what we do